so let's go
over how I understand the uh attack they
attack
okay um one as I said strategically is
teaching you rotation and counter
rotation okay and we've talked a lot
about that um but what's happening here
is some what if training which is why
I'm not really a fan of this okay which
we we don't do this too often
um pretty much everything you do here is
uh Uchi Ken you're going to work with
Uchi Ken so a lot of stuff we just do
from katate or kadori and and just work
GUI K okay uh what do I mean by what if
is she's in
h and she is going to have her hand out
like katate okay
and I am going to
push from
here
into this position
here so already in normal
coor I would just spinally
displace but this one is going to check
and spinally
displace and so sometimes you can have
your hand up higher okay and uh I reach
and then what if he grabs checks and
finally displaced so the check here is
just pin against the body and you have
all your stripes
okay so that is what I'm
doing she's going to counter that with
the first move so what you go
yes and so I fall into empty space
okay and if you watch and we'll use
different angles on the camera so we'll
show it from here first as I go boom she
is now at the flank to
me okay and so I have to UNF flank
myself and that's what this step is
doing
here we'll show it more time let's do it
from this Angle
now so again what am I doing she'll let
me do it this time is I am checking in
spal this
place she counters that by
avoiding and now I'm being flanked so I
UNF flank Myself by coming to the back
of her body okay
and that is what's just happening more
smoothly as we go around okay once I'm
at the back of the
body I seek those training control
points of katate
okay and now I finally
displace from the rear
so we'll do it
again boom unfl flank myself finally
displaced from the
rear of course you saw the throw though
okay so that is what's
happening boom boom
boom you think you got a good angle okay
okay so we go really slow so I can talk
so
here I absorb let that void and I bit
her with what she wants
okay do that
again boom absorb so that does there's
no there's none of her Mass on that
right now for example if I was here she
can push me and I feel her mou so I take
that to zero pressure okay okay I don't
take it to POS negative like that I'm
not pulling
her hence I say I
avoid whom I bait her
okay boom hands back
here I don't keep my hand here she's
never going to get it
okay
now I bait
her boy
bait when I bait I don't give her this
hand then it's back behind me okay stay
there I go
again I have to keep it in front where
there it is don't let her pull it
back the other one's fine for now boom
stays in front okay all right we'll try
that baiting I'm doing that same
thing and when you bait it's Palm up not
Palm down bait Palm up
okay and now I got to B the rules don't
stop UK okay so that means as I bait
here I bring her around you
sming again I'm not pulling her around
I'm baiting her
around
moving this is a combination of my hand
going this way but a combination too of
my feet moving
foot and hand
move keep UK
moving and as you do that you kind let
your hands go back
there so you have inor
spiral this
way inward inward spiral this way
okay and my hands stay in front of
me okay TR all right so the technique
now again like I said there's a lot of
wh ifs that's happening here okay so if
you pay
attention is my back here right and if I
stay still she'd have my
back and I'm going to keep her moving
she's not going to have that back you
see that now again when you fight you
realize that anyone that almost has your
back will keep trying to get your back
it happens all the time so it seems
crazy that someone would go around but
they do they do all the time okay
they're trying to get to the back I just
can't be too far ahead of them I just
got to be just
enough to give them the corner that they
think they can get around and get at the
back okay so in other words this is too
far that becomes stupid okay but also
this is stupid too this isn't going to
work okay I'm just inside where I keep
egging her around that corner trying to
get it okay all right next let's pay
attention to what happens to the grips
with the inward spiral okay so we'll
watch this s
okay there she was at the
bait but as I start to go around you
start to
have
this wedging out that starts to happen
Okay as you're continuing your inward
spirals what I want to
do is give her
that and not wedge out when you feel
yourself wedging out that means you've
hit the in phase of that technique and
you need to transition okay if you watch
on this hand it's going to happen too
it's right here which is what you want
on this hand I want to more or less
escape from this grip
okay it's this hand that we have to do
something different we starts in the
inward spiral but then it gives her that
where I hold her now
okay and I
hold to hold
her I make these very small steps where
my feet are
together side by side which is always
the launching point for Pok ho
want to have my feet like
that okay I have to turn and bring my
feet Side
by okay we'll try that okay now now I
have to do all of
that and get into C hole position which
is right here on the side stay where you
are please and let go though okay this
is where koku ho is we are facing the
same
direction and I am on either the front
[Music]
corner or the back corner that is where
you are okay if you were on the back
corner you always have to bring her head
this way first
okay if I'm on the front corner I'm
already in place I don't have to do it
okay but that's where I want to end up
so one two and I end up don't don't turn
for me please just do your thing your
thing and that's where I am up okay do
it again
boom
boom I
do One More
Time
Boom Boom turn now this turning is
coiling her around
me this way
boiling but I'm right at the edge okay
right at the edge that gets her going
and changes her Direction so here she's
going forward when I coil she's going
backward
[Music]
okay we'll try it go okay let's look
let's go into that a little bit this is
where you had problems the most cuz your
UK is looking the wrong way which means
if I didn't turn my UK okay but my Desy
to are having problems with it okay um
if I just grab that hand and you push
okay with your whole body it pushes with
your whole body
and she
pushes and you saw that eventually her
back turned
okay go
slow pretend you're
pushing okay and eventually this body
turned
okay
um that's what's happening
here so I she's going forward
and I have to take this
hand and make it go here so her body
turns okay one more
time so this
hand this
hand is going to make this
go like that okay it is
not going to make it go go this
way has to have our turn around okay so
let's look at where it does it okay we
just pay attention to this so this hand
has to make that
Circle okay and the way it makes that
Circle it has to turn her so if stay
where you are please if I am over
here and I made
contact she's not going to turn you're
just pushing her
forward that's what Juka did a forward
roll I have to have the understanding
that I'm going to make her Boom turn
like
that okay how do I do the
turn you have to use of course you got
to be in the right space time so the M
has to be right for that sometimes
you're too far ahead too far out you
can't do it okay but the mechanism once
you have the right mind is going to be
your adhesions okay so we'll have her
release her grip okay you're going to
adhere
here I'll have
her um press her Palm on me so my hand
is adhering
is my point not my grip I'm not pulling
her her Palm is on me and my wrist
adheres as
well my body is not this far from her
but it starts to wrap okay and she will
eventually feel me on my back on her
arm okay she feels that
and so that is what I'm using on the
adhesion this is the mechanism of the
turn I know what the turn needs to do
and I know I have to be in a certain
space time to make that happen because I
need her to turn around so all that I do
boom there's the
turn boom
and then for this technique for khole I
have to be I'm going to slow it down I
have to
be very close here stay there please on
this front
corner okay so that my hand
raises and takes the top part of the
toxic
turbine we'll go back
again boom there's the turn
here's that hand and my we are looking
the same way so I turn till I keep
looking the same way and she turned
around and then my feet will be behind
her and that's where the x pattern is
here so go one boom I turn her I'm there
in place in I go okay so I'll take the x
pattern out here Yas can't do it so but
everything else is the
[Music]
same turn her
there so even if I don't do the x
pattern you should still
[Music]
step as perpendicular to her angle of
disturbance as possible
so that you don't
go this way parallel to
it so I won't
displace but I'm kind of diagonal
to this
way boom
okay lastly let's look at the Y hand at
the end and let us understand that this
khole is actually an inward
spiral going
up I know it looks like this but we
don't have that shape
okay so it goes up and I am turning is
what's
happening so if you mark my elbow here I
am again on that 12 to six line so as it
goes up if I stay still my elbow stays
on that 12 to six
line but as I turn that elbow is moving
West and it's coming on this side of the
line
okay and this is how you do all of the C
hole of this very end okay so it's
always this shape and I've turned inside
of
it never this shape and this they always
look like that but it's not that okay
again I don't have this
shape so we go do that side again and
we're going to wash this hand now okay
as it goes so it goes into the inward
spiral up keep your grips
up you see and as I'm turning as I'm
starting to turn her we'll let go of
that for now you can see that you're
going to get the
adhesion on the chin I'm s on the her
cheek and my
shoulder okay and I'm coming inside her
grip inside her grip the elbows already
touching
her what would be
different is I'm going into her elbow
you're trying to do that do you see so
most choreograph UK will let you do that
and you then you're here you see that
but what you want to do is get away stay
there please you want to get away from
that angle that angle she's strong on
that's where everyone goes and usually
the UK lets you go okay so I don't push
on that angle the hand's going this
way and then I find that and then the
body goes and as her body goes that's
when this hand can now F into
space so don't
smell
this you keep the shape the shape boom
that's what you
want
[Music]
boom inward spiral
around
resistance
up that also raises your center of
gravity which makes the X powder much
easier okay so we'll do it again without
the X powder